d'abord bonsoir et je vais essayer pas
trop vous embêter comme c'est la fin
soirée
mais mon propos aujourd'hui ces deux
peut-être très bien contre tendance de
beaucoup de choses et de vous parler de
l'humain dans le marketing alors et
surtout de vous montrer combien une
démarche humaine dans le marketing peut
amener à la performance dans
l'entreprise puisque l'objectif c'est là
alors c'est un peu bizarre de parler de
ça puisque on est quand même à l'ère du
big data
on est à l'ère des crm surdéveloppé on
est à l'ère où un croisement un bon
croisement de parts de base de données
vous permet de savoir laquelle la
couleur des caleçons de chacun mais moi
je vous parle de comment est-ce qu'on va
remettre l'être humain au milieu de tout
ça aujourd'hui les départements
marketing ils passent énormément de
temps à définir le quoi le coincer le
produit c'est ce que l'on va vendre
alors passé beaucoup de temps là-dessus
ensuite on va passer beaucoup de temps
sur wii mais à qui va-t-on le ventre le
qui est donc on se lance dans ces
grandes analyses sur lucky troisième
source de dépense d'énergie d'un
département marketing c'est comment est
ce qu'on prend le quoi et on prend le
qui est on le met ensemble c'est le
comment et il ya très très peu de temps
qu'ils sont des pensées qui est dépensé
par un département et par les gens pour
dire mais pourquoi fait-on ça et le
pourquoi c'est ce qui donne le sens à ce
qu'on fait c'est comment pourquoi est ce
que mon entreprise existe pourquoi est
ce qu'elle propose quelque chose
pourquoi est ce que un consommateur
potentiel va choisir mon entreprise
plutôt qu'une autre va choisir ma marque
plutôt qu'une autre
c'est vraiment le retour au sens et
c'est un peu toute la démarche que
aujourd'hui on oublie de faire et qui
qui est fondamental on vit vraiment dans
un monde assez paradoxale au 21ème
siècle puisque à la fois on a des
technologies de l'information qui nous
permette véritablement de la sphère de
la segmentation ultime
on peut savoir la segmentation le team
savais juste que jusqu'au client
lui-même
on va s'intéresser on va dire jusqu'au
client on va savoir ce qu'ils consomment
enfin savoir ce qu'il a acheté on va
savoir ce qu'il détient on va savoir
sont à voir mais on va extrêmement pu
s'intéresser à ce qu'il est et à ses
aspirations profondes
pourtant c'est quand même ça qui va
donner le sens et qui va haute après
permettre véritablement les choix d'un
consommateur c'est ce qu'il est
véritablement est pas tellement ce que
ce qu'ils achètent ou ce que ce qui l'a
alors et les grandes sociétés de
consultance aujourd'hui on vous propose
des outils fantastiques et je crache pas
du tout de suite parce qu'on les utilise
et ils sont très très utiles mais ce
sont que des outils mais ces outils
ils sont hissés rva quoi bein c'est un
peu ils sont présentés comme le saint
graal du marketing moderne
un peu comme l'ordinateur et est
représenté comme le saint graal de la
conquête spatiale
ce sont des hommes qui ont été sur la
lune auquel auraient pas été sans
l'ordinateur leur marketing c'est la
même chose on fait un métier pour des
hommes et par des zones et on utilise
des outils et il faut surtout pas
positionné l'outil comme étant la fin
mais vraiment uniquement comme un des
moyens qui permet de faire quelque chose
qui fait du sens alors je vous propose
vraiment de revenir à la base à la base
de la démarche marketing et donc
certainement pas cracher sur les outils
parce qu'ils sont ils sont là ils sont
nécessaires ils sont vraiment très très
utile en arriver à faire des trucs
fantastiques avec ça mais de se poser de
se poser les questions de fond c'est à
dire que quand on commence une
entreprise quand on démarre une activité
ou un nouveau produit on va se poser
d'abord la question de savoir où est ce
que je vis et donc il faut d'abord
comprendre la société dans laquelle on
est et surtout se positionner par
rapport à cette société et puis surtout
à les déterminer les tendances lourdes
de cette société et ses tendances
lourdes de ces sociétés c'est celle où
je vais dire je vais choisir quelles
tendances pour positionner mon
entreprise pour des positionner le mât
démarche commerciale pour avoir une
chance de succès il faut un peu voir
cette tendance comme un fleuve aux
communes rivière donc on a le choix de
choisir l'endroit où on va aller
naviguer ça c'est la première premier
choix et puis on a le choix
est-ce que je vais à contre-courant ou
est-ce que je vais dans le courant
inutile de dire que quand on va à
contre-courant va dépenser beaucoup
d'énergie pour pas avancé pour pas
avancer grand chose quand on se met dans
le courant simplement on va pouvoir se
laisser porter et décider en poussant sa
baraque à gauche ou à droite si on va
aller plus à gauche ou à droite et donc
on va pouvoir minimiser ces ressources
est maximisée maximiser ses effets alors
dans le cadre de lampiris les tendances
lourdes sais quoi parce qu'il faut un
ampli c'est quand même un vendeur
d'énergie
fister le gaz il n'y a pas beaucoup de
produits moins sexy que ça donc à vendre
c'est pas facile c'est directement ce
qu'on va se différencier
ça se bouge pas enfin quand ça se touche
ça fait très mal
l'électricité le client et nous voient
comme en bas il reçoit une facture
super et comment va pouvoir se
différencier bien nous en être décidé de
se donner du sens à ce qu'on fait en
choisissant des tendances lourdes de
marché et en deuxième lieu de pouvoir
développer toutes nos stratégies toutes
nos actions par rapport à ceux à autant
dans ce qu on a chaud condra show qu'on
a choisi alors une tendance lourde comme
j'ai dit c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on peut retrouver sur plusieurs
décennies qu'on va retrouver des signes
de s'étendant sur énormément de marché
ils seraient énormément de choses mais
qu'on relit pas forcément entre ensemble
la première tendance
et bien c'est l'individualisme on est
dans un monde de plus en plus en plus
individualiste ça veut dire quoi qu'il
ya vraiment une primauté de l'individu
sur le groupe
on aime on n'aime pas c'est comme ça et
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est le sommet de
l'individualisme ce sont les réseaux
sociaux c'est moi comme individu je me
montre et je montre aux autres individus
l'importance que j'ai et l'influent ce
que je veux avoir sur le reste du monde
alors quand on y lire identifie une
tendance ours comme ça il ya absolument
aucun jugement de valeur
comme je disais on aime on n'aime pas
c'est pas ça qui est important ce qui
était important c'est comment va-t-on
positionner son entreprise va t'on
développer son approche marketing pour
bénéficier de cette tendance et de
pouvoir être vrai par rapport à cette
tendance
alors au bout du compte le but c'est de
générer du profit pour une entreprise
commerciale
c'est comme ça et donc seuls en piste
qu'est ce qu'on a dit ben voilà c'est
une tendance importante et pour nous il
est fondamental qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va d'abord mettre notre client ou
même le client potentiel au coeur de la
marque c'est à dire qu'on va lui
proposer de construire notre marque
avait avec nous et donc on va lui poser
des tas de questions on va le laisser à
interagir y ait en permanence chaque
fois qu'on a quelque chose à construire
on va lui poser des questions
on va lui permettre de s'exprimer et pas
seulement par des grandes études de
marché anonyme mais vraiment en direct
on va pouvoir me permettre de s'exprimer
ça c'est une première chose la deuxième
chose c'est qu'on a décidé de m
transparence comme étant une des valeurs
fondatrices de lattre de l'entreprise
donc sur les réseaux sociaux
si vous n'êtes pas transparent si vous
n'êtes pas honnête vous êtes juste cuit
donc on a décidé vraiment de positionner
sa et que dans tous nos actes on puisse
vraiment pouvoir
on devrait pouvoir en permanence avoir
une transparence qui soit la plus élévée
irréprochable possible
et puis on a créé des plateformes de
patron de discussion où l'ensemble de
nos clients peuvent vraiment interagir
et avec nous-mêmes et on va répondre et
on va le faire en toute transparence et
c'est devenu un réflexe quand on se pose
une question d'un sur n'importe quoi sur
une action et on va lui demander au
client
si vous vous posez une question de
savoir si votre niveau de service assez
haut par rapport aux attentes des
clients il faut poser devant des clients
il faut pas le demander aux clients se
cachant il faut le faire en life il faut
surtout mettre sa marque en danger en
permanence et y aller et il ouvrira tout
le monde est et non un le client n'a pas
toujours raison mais par contre il faut
le mieux laisser dire aux autres clients
quand il y en a qui a pas raison que
ledit soi même et ça marche
alors un petit truc pour arriver à ça
dans le son entreprise va il faut
commencer par le faire en interne
si vous mettez la co création au sein de
vente de vos employés si vous mettez cet
esprit coco création si vous laisser les
portes ouvertes à ce que chacun peut
avoir une bonne idée qui a peut avoir
une influence qu complète et bien
defacto vous allez avoir que l'ensemble
de vos employés vont mettre vos clients
dans le même jus et donc on va se
retrouver dans la dent dans dans un
aspect où chacun va pouvoir avoir
l'impression d'avoir construit et plus
que l'impression d'avoir véritablement
construit la marque alors le deuxième
deuxième quand on danse sur laquelle on
a construit c'est c'est que aujourd'hui
il ya de plus en plus de gens ont
conscience que leurs actes ont des
conséquences que l'acte d'achat n'est
pas seulement le fait d'acheter quelque
chose mais que derrière il va y avoir
une prise de conscience par de plus en
plus de gens de sa a été fabriqué
comment dans quelles conditions le
bénéfice il va vers qui est ce que ce
bénéfice est bon pour la société
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans mon assiette
tout ça ce sont des questions qui sont
vraiment des choses qui étaient très peu
présentes il ya une quelques années et
qui aujourd'hui sont de plus en plus le
rôle quelques exemples
il ya quelques années une dizaine
d'années le nombre de mes traits dans un
supermarché donc le nombre de mètres de
rayonnages dans un marché qui était
dédiée aux produits fairtrade ou aux
produits bio c'était extrêmement limité
aujourd'hui on a cole rutilance des
marques
on accole re qui lancent des chaînes une
chaîne de supermarchés bio c'est pas la
grande distribution qui amène à tendance
la grande distribution elle répond à une
tendance donc on a bon ça on a vraiment
ça qui entre le monde automobile
utilisent des arguments aux veines
environnementaux pour vendre des dépôts
vendre des véhicules
le taux de co2 est utilisé le niveau de
recyclabilité des rites il est utilisé
on va avoir comme ça sur même des
grandes marques de nourriture donc je
sais pas si vous avez vu dano marque des
petits drapeaux belges sur certains
produits pour dire que c'est fabriqué
localement avec des produits locaux et
ça c'est vraiment une tendance lourde
importante alors quand on est un
fournisseur de gaz exister que moi ce
qu'on fait pour se mettre sur cette
tendance toujours c'est bien
d'identifier comment va-t-on mettre son
entreprise bain dès le premier jour
qu'on a décidé de vendre les les grilles
de l'électricité verte
on a décidé de travailler sur le gaz
naturel qui est l'énergie fossile la
moins polluante
on a décidé de développer des solutions
qui permet de consommer moins d'énergie
et donc de réduire son impact écologique
on a décidé que tous les gens qui
travailleraient travail pour nous
travaillerons sont des brouillons des
travailleurs locaux qui vivent ici en
belgique on a décidé d'acheter notre
énergie la majeure partie notre énergie
à des producteurs indépendants locales
et j'en passe et des meilleurs mets donc
c'est vraiment chaque action après que
l'on fait que l'on soit en interne ou en
externe passe par un filtre de trois
valeurs qui sont l'aspect durable
l'aspect humain et l'aspect local
c'est un choix c'est une manière jamais
qu'une illustration de montrer comment
sont sur une tendance
la troisième tendance s'est on est
scellé on est dans une société où la
plupart d'entre nous on cherche de
nouvelles références
beaucoup de gens ont perdu confiance
dans les références traditionnelles
avant on avait l'église l'état l'armée
l'enseignement l'instituteur le notaire
le curé tout le monde ça c'était les
références étaient en cours avec
confiance
cette confiance est existe plus telle
qu'elle allait tourner très critique et
donc pouvoir construire une marque ou
une société dans laquelle qui deviennent
une référence de confiance est un
facteur de différenciation important
alors la confiance ça ne s'achète pas ça
ne se décrète pas ça se mérite
alors comment on fait pour mériter la
confiance oui un bon service de qualité
oui une transparence une transparence
dans tout dans tout ce qu'on fait et
aussi des prises de position et des
prises de position dans la société
donc clairement nous on a décidé d'être
premiers jours on va être le robin des
bois du marchix l'énergie c'est un
marché qui est trusté par des sociétés
internationales on va se positionner
comme étant le robin des bois celui qui
casse les règles du jeu et qui fait tout
autrement
ça c'était un premier exemple alors
comment on a fait pour être voir des
bois
ok on a décidé de casser la règle de la
friterie des frais de rupture pour les
clients continuent quand il quand il
nous quitte on a décidé de pride de deux
mètres le prix du gaz aux prix du gaz et
plus haut prix du pétrole
on a on a décidé de sortir de la
sacro-sainte fédération énergétique
belge pour pouvoir marquer notre
différence
on est on a par exemple dans le cadre du
black out où on a entendu des blackhawks
bien tout le marché de l'énergie était
de dire où on va pas trop en parler on
va pas prendre position parce que sinon
on va être tenu comme responsable
on a décidé de prendre un verre sont ali
ben nous on va pratiquement prendre
prendre une position et on va de nouveau
proposé aux citoyens de devenir acteur
acteurs par ce qui peut avoir un impact
est plus dans la position dans laquelle
était c'est-à-dire était de potions deux
otages de nouveau ces exemples pour dire
comment est ce que on se positionne sur
une tendance de recherche de référence
et comment est-ce qu'on peut devenir une
marque dans lequel on fait on nous
ferons on peut nous faire confiance
la quatrième tendance c'est
véritablement le fait qu' on n'achète
plus un bien comme on lâche t il
hier on n'achète plus un service que mon
lâcheté hier pour thésauriser pour avoir
des choses dans son armoire
on veut vivre des expériences et vous
avez des marques qui ont très bien
compris ça quand vous aviez votre café
chez nespresso
vous vivez une expérience différente
quand vous allez voir un spectacle de
cirque au cirque du soleil
vous vivez tout à fait une expérience
tout à fait différente du spectacle d'un
cirque normal quand vous allez à
tomorrowland vous vivez une expérience
tout à fait différente indépendant de la
qualité des artistes qui se produisent
au festival ce sont des choses qui sont
différents et nous on a décidé bon enfin
la revanche avec du gaz électricité donc
comment faire des expériences avec du
gaz électricité et bien on a dit m tous
les points de contact qu'on a avec nos
clients doivent être d'y faire une
différence et doivent amener une
expérience positive alors un exemple
quand vous téléphonez chez nous et bien
le répondeur maximum deux étapes avant
que on est quelqu'un en ligne pourquoi
parce que vous connaissez tous les
fameux répondeur ou balade dans les
annales aude
on veut vivre autre chose les gens qui
répondent au téléphone ils n'ont pas de
script
ils sont à mesurer dans le temps ils
doivent répondre à votre question et
leur deuxième objectif le plus important
c'est qu'ils doivent avoir un moment
agréable passé avec vous ça doit être
agréable pour pour vous savez très
agréable pour lui et d'avoir vécu
quelque chose de différent
ça ce sont des exemples la dernire
gageure qu'on s'était mis la dernière
vraiment le challenge c'est qu'on s'est
dit mais comment on va faire pour qu'un
client qu'il soit une facture de nous
dans sa boîte email ils aient envie de
l'ouvrir bien ça c'était une gageure
et donc ça c'est un tout un travail ton
état d'esprit que le que l'on créé dans
la dans la société vont dire mais
comment est-ce que chaque fois que j'ai
un contact je fais quelque chose de
différent pour mes clients j'ai plus
permet d'avoir d'avoir une expérience
alors au total je reviens vraiment à
l'aspect fondamental d'une entreprise
commerciale d'abord donc c'est de cesser
de faire du profit c'est d'avoir du
succès et je crois que le marché sur la
lune est allé sur la lune pour une
entreprise c'est d'abord bien démarré et
c'est surtout tenir dans la durée et
donc tenir dans la durée
ça veut dire être capable de développer
de développer une marque crédible sur
son marché est très développé une marque
est capable d'aller chercher d'autres
marchés
pas seulement sur son marché à soit tu
peux aller voir d'autres marchés et
surtout une marque qui génère des
sentiments positifs et c'est sur ces
sentiments positifs cola et sur cette
sympathique qu'on leur a créé quand la
pouvoir construire une relation pérenne
avec nos clients une relation pérenne
même avec des gens qui ne sont pas
clients chez nous ce qui nous quitte on
continue
relation continue alors je vous
proposerai pour chacun d'entre vous vous
êtes toujours des associations vous êtes
tous des entrées dans des entreprises
mais simplement de petits en passer un
tout petit peu de temps pour savoir
identifier
mais sur quelles tendances de marché je
suis en train d'agir sur quelles
tendances je suis en train de surfer et
sur quelles tendances j'ai mis mon
bateau sur lequel rivière j'ai mis mon
bateau potillon c'est pas très compliqué
on y peut l'identifier assez facilement
et ça va servir de moteur pour la suite
petit 2 de se dire mais quelles sont les
valeurs de mes clients ou des gens qui
sont en interaction avec moi les valeurs
de leur valeur que j'aimerais vraiment
bien qu'il puisse retrouver dans mon
entreprise et dans ma marque
ça c'est vraiment le petit 2 et le
troisième c'est quand on a identifié ces
valeurs c'est de voir comment est-ce
qu'on peut aligner toutes ces valeurs
entre tous les acteurs de l'entreprise
aussi bien le conseil d'administration
les employés le management la direction
les clients les fournisseurs et de faire
un alignement le plus le plus le plus
loin possible dans une réalité
économique parce qu'on est dans une
réalité économique entre ces valeurs
et si on doit faire un moonshot
aujourd'hui pour reprendre le thème mais
je pense ce serait simplement de dire
les outils c'est super au marketing et
ça doit vraiment être bien connu et bien
utilisé mais peut-être que faire le pas
le pas sur le pas le vrai pas c'est de
faire du marketing avec du coeur alors
ses 10 ans grand mot belle phrase ça
veut dire quoi peut-être juste commencer
par aligner les valeurs de la marque que
l'on défend avec ses valeurs
personnelles et quand on fait ça je
pense que on a une chance de marque
faire plus de marketing humain et plus
de marketing avec son coeur